en fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait
besoin de producteurs déjà moi je peux
vous faire des instruits puisque la voix
rapper sur des instrus de des faces b
quoi et après nous on y met à
disposition le studio on enregistre
votre album on fait vos clips la
stratégie tout ça après vous pourriez
vivre de votre musique
et depuis vous avez pas fini un seul
[ __ ] de morceau non mais ça prend du
temps de faire un bon morceau ça quand
même on peut pas aller plus vite que la
musique
elle arrête de te [ __ ] de ma gueule
grincheuse effet cette maquette en cinq
ans il ya trois blagues de cul un truc
sur le wonder caché ya rien de fini
c'est parce qu'on essaie de faire un
clip mais il n'y a pas de morceaux fini
tu veux clip est quoi
stupide le premier clip au monde à base
de caméra de surveillance
attendez les gars c'est une blague soit
possible c'est pas une blague gras c'est
bon on arrête tout on arrête là on
arrête on range le matos on arrête de
payer loyer vous faites votre vie on
fait comment pour payer le loyer avec qu
elle allait réfléchir avant direct en a
rien à [ __ ]
on n'arrête pas de sart bonne et on
bosse en bosse en foutez rien tout est
normal
et si on vous fait un son pour demain
vous êtes déjà pas capable de me sortir
en 105 ans vont parler de faire en sorte
pour demain mais ça va ne sous-estiment
pas non plus mais vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire et c'est les mecs mais
si on est capable menottes et sa cape
ann non mais sinon mes six mois noisy
banon et simon alain si ben non moi je
te dis que c'est mon devoir c'est bon
c'est bon c'est quoi
vous faites un marché où les gars nous
on revient demain même heure on voit ce
qu'on fait ok
une fête manquant un morceau sur
l'alcool ou aux blagues de cul au caire
c'est un son qui parle aux gens